OPERATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, if you remember,
just before the
break, as long ago as it was,
we had looked at the problem
of fitting curves to data.
And the example we had seen, is
that it's often possible,
in fact, usually possible, to
find a good fit to old values.
What we looked at was, we looked
at a small number of
points, we took a high degree
polynomial, sure enough, we
got a great fit.
The difficulty was, a great
fit to old values does not
necessarily imply a good
fit to new values.
And in general, that's
somewhat worrisome.
So now I want to spend a little
bit of time I'm looking
at some tools, that we can use
to better understand the
notion of, when we have a
bunch of points, what
do they look like?
How does the variation work?
This gets back to a concept that
we've used a number of
times, which is a notion
of a distribution.
Remember, the whole logic
behind our idea of using
simulation, or polling, or any
kind of statistical technique,
is the assumption that the
values we would draw were
representative of the values
of the larger population.
We're sampling some subset of
the population, and we're
assuming that that sample is
representative of the greater
population.
We talked about several
different
issues related to that.
I now want to look at that a
little bit more formally.
And we'll start with the very
old problem of rolling dice.
I presume you've all
seen what a pair of
dice look like, right?
They've got the numbers 1
through 6 on them, you roll
them and something comes up.
If you haven't seen it, if you
look at the very back, at the
back page of the handout today,
you'll see a picture of
a very old die.
Some time from the fourth to
the second century BC.
Looks remarkably like a modern
dice, except it's not made out
of plastic, it's made
out of bones.
And in fact, if you were
interested in the history of
gambling, or if you happen to
play with dice, people do call
them bones.
And that just dates back to
the fact that the original
ones were made that way.
And in fact, what we'll see
is, that in the history of
probability and statistics, an
awful lot of the math that we
take for granted today, came
from people's attempts to
understand various
games of chance.
So, let's look at it.
So we'll look at this program.
You should have this in the
front of the handout.
So I'm going to start
with a fair dice.
That is to say, when you roll
it, it's equally probable that
you get 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, or 6.
And I'm going to throw a pair.
You can see it's very simple.
I'll take d 1, first die is
random dot choice from vals 1.
d 2 will be random dot
choice from vals 2.
So I'm going to pass it in two
sets of possible values, and
randomly choose one or the
other, and then return them.
And the way I'll conduct a
trial is, I'll take some
number of throws, and two
different kinds of dice.
Throws will be the empty
set, actually, yeah.
And then I'll just do it.
For i in range number of throws,
d 1, d 2 is equal to
throw a pair, and then
I'll append it, and
then I'll return it.
Very simple, right?
Could hardly imagine a simpler
little program.
And then, we'll analyze it.
And we're going to analyze it.
Well, first let's analyze it one
way, and then we'll look
at something slightly
different.
I'm going to conduct some
number of trials
with two fair die.
Then I'm going to make a
histogram, because I happen to
know that there are only
11 possible values,
I'll make 11 bins.
You may not have seen
this locution
here, Pylab dot x ticks.
That's telling it where to put
the markers on the x-axis, and
what they should be.
In this case 2 through 12,
and then I'll label it.
So let's run this program.
And here we see the distribution
of values.
So we see that I get more 7s
than anything else, and fewer
2s and 12s.
Snake eyes and boxcars
to you gamblers.
And it's a beautiful
distribution, in some sense.
I ran it enough trials.
This kind of distribution
is called normal.
Also sometimes called
Gaussian, after the
mathematician Gauss.
Sometimes called the bell curve,
because in someone's
imagination it looks
like a bell.
We see these things
all the time.
They're called normal, or
sometimes even natural,
because it's probably the most
commonly observed probability
distribution in nature.
First documented, although I'm
sure not first seen, by
deMoivre and Laplace
in the 1700s.
And then in the 1800s, Gauss
used it to analyze
astronomical data.
And it got to be called, in
that case, the Gaussian
distribution.
So where do we see it occur?
We see it occurring all
over the place.
We certainly see it
rolling dice.
We see it occur in things like
the distribution of heights.
If we were to take the height of
all the students at MIT and
plot the distribution, I would
be astonished if it didn't
look more or less like that.
It would be a normal
distribution.
A lot of things in
the same height.
Now presumably, we'd have to
round off to the nearest
millimeter or something.
And a few really tall people,
and a few really short people.
It's just astonishing in nature
how often we look at
these things.
The graph looks exactly like
that, or similar to that.
The shape is roughly that.
The normal distribution can be
described, interestingly
enough, with just two numbers.
The mean and the standard
deviation.
So if I give you those
two numbers, you
can draw that curve.
Now you might not be able to
label, you couldn't label the
axes, because how would
you know how many
trials I did, right?
Whether I did 100, or 1,000 or a
million, but the shape would
always be the same.
And if I were to, instead of
doing, 100,000 throws of the
dice, as I did here, I did a
million, the label on the
y-axis would change,
but the shape would
be absolutely identical.
This is what's called a
stable distribution.
As you change the scale, the
shape doesn't change.
So the mean tells us where
it's centered, and the
standard deviation, basically,
is a measure of statistical
dispersion.
It tells us how widely
spread the points of
the data set are.
If many points are going to be
very close to the mean, then
the standard deviation is
what, big or small?
Pardon?
Small.
If they're spread out, and it's
kind of a flat bell, then
the standard deviation
will be large.
And I'm sure you've all seen
standard deviations.
We give exams, and we say here's
the mean, here's the
standard deviation.
And the notion is, that's trying
to tell you what the
average score was, and how
spread out they are.
Now as it happens, rarely do
we have exams that actually
fall on a bell curve.
Like this.
So in a way, don't be deceived
by thinking that we're really
giving you a good measure of the
dispersion, in the sense,
that we would get with
the bell curve.
So the standard deviation does
have a formal value, usually
written sigma, and it's the
estimates of x squared minus
the estimates of x, and then
I take all of this, the
estimates of x, right,
squared.
So I don't worry much about
this, but what I'm basically
doing is, x is all of the
values I have. And I can
square each of the values, and
then I subtract from that, the
sum of the values,
squaring that.
What's more important than this
formula, for most uses,
is what people think of as the
-- why didn't I write it down
-- this is interesting.
There is a some number --
I see why, I did write
it down, it just
got printed on two-sided.
Is the Empirical Rule.
And this applies for normal
distributions.
So anyone know how much of the
data that you should expect to
fall within one standard
deviation of the mean?
68.
So 68% within one, 95% of the
data falls within two, and
almost all of the data
within three.
These values are approximations,
by the way.
So, this is, really 95% falls
within 1.96 standard
deviations, it's not two.
But this gives you a sense
of how spread out it is.
And again, this applies only
for a normal distribution.
If you compute the standard
deviation this way, and apply
it to something other than a
normal distribution, there's
no reason to expect that
Empirical Rule will hold.
OK people with me on this?
It's amazing to me how many
people in society talk about
standard deviations
without actually
knowing what they are.
And there's another way to
look at the same data, or
almost the same data.
Since it's a random experiment,
it won't be
exactly the same.
So as before, we had the
distribution, and fortunately
it looks pretty much
like the last one.
We would've expected that.
And I've now done something,
another way of looking at the
same information, really, is,
I printed, I plotted, the
probabilities of different
values.
So we can see here that the
probability of getting a 7 is
about 0.17 or something
like that.
Now, since I threw 100,000 die,
it's not surprising that
the probability of 0.17
looks about the same
as 17,000 over here.
But it's just a different way
of looking at things.
Right, had I thrown some
different number, it might
have been harder to visualize
what the probability
distribution looked like.
But we often do talk
about that.
How probable is a
certain value?
People who design games of
chance, by the way, something
I've been meaning to say.
You'll notice down here there's
just, when we want to
save these things, there's
this little icon that's a
floppy disk, to indicate
store.
And I thought maybe many of
you'd never seen a floppy
disk, so I decided
to bring one in.
You've seen the icons.
And probably by the time most of
you got, any you ever had a
machine with a quote
floppy drive?
Did it actually flop the disk?
No, they were pretty rigid, but
the old floppy disks were
really floppy.
Hence they got the name.
And, you know it's kind of like
a giant size version.
And it's amazing how people will
probably continue to talk
about floppy disks as
long as they talk
about dialing a telephone.
And probably none of you've ever
actually dialed a phone,
for that matter, just
pushed buttons .
But they used to have dials
that you would twirl.
Anyway, I just thought everyone
should at least see a
floppy disk once.
This is, by the way, a very good
way to get data security.
There's probably no way in the
world to read the information
on this disk anymore.
All right, as I said people
who design games of chance
understand these probabilities
very well.
So I'm gonna now look at, show
how we can understand these
things in some other ways
of popular example.
A game of dice.
Has anyone here ever played
the game called craps?
Did you win or lose money?
You won.
All right, you beat the odds.
Well, it's a very popular
game, and I'm going to
explain it to you.
As you will see, this is not
an endorsement of gambling,
because one of the things you
will notice is, you are likely
to lose money if you do this.
So I tend not, I don't do it.
All right, so how does
a game of craps work?
You start by rolling two dice.
If you get a 7 or an 11, the
roller, we'll call that the
shooter, you win.
If you get a 2, 3, or
a 12, you lose.
I'm assuming here, you're
betting what's
called the pass line.
There are different ways to bet,
this is the most common
way to bet, we'll just
deal with that.
If it's not any of these, what
you get is, otherwise, the
number becomes what's
called the point.
Once you've got the point, you
keep rolling the dice until 1
of o things happens.
You get a 7, in which case you
lose, or you get the point, in
which case you win.
So it's a pretty simple game.
Very popular game.
So I've implemented.
So one of the interesting things
about this is, if you
try and actually figure out
what the probabilities are
using pencil and paper,
you can, but it gets
a little bit involved.
Gets involved because you have
to, all right, what are the
odds of winning or losing
on the first throw?
Well, you can compute those
pretty easily, and you can see
that you'd actually win
more than you lose,
on the first throw.
But if you look at the
distribution of 7s and 11s and
2s, 3s, and 12s, you add them
up, you'll see, well, this is
more likely than this.
But then you say, suppose
I don't get those.
What's the likelihood of getting
each other possible
point value, and then given that
point value, what's the
likelihood of getting
that before a 7?
And you can do it, but
it gets very tedious.
So those of us who are
inclined to think
computationally, and I hope by
now that's all of you as well
as me, say well, instead of
doing the probabilities by
hand, I'm just going to write
a little program.
And it's a program that took me
maybe 10 minutes to write.
You can see it's quite small,
I did it yesterday.
So the first function here is
craps, it returns true if the
shooter wins by betting
the pass line.
And it's just does
what I said.
Rolls them, if the total
is 1 or 11, it
returns true, you win.
If it's 2, 3, or 12, it returns
false, you lose.
Otherwise the point
becomes the total.
And then while true, I'll
just keep rolling.
Until either, if the total gets
the point, I return true.
Or if the total's equal
7, I return false.
And that's it.
So essentially I just took these
rules, typed them down,
and I had my game.
And then I'll simulate it will
some number of bets.
Keeping track of the numbers
of wins and losses.
Just by incrementing 1 or the
other, depending upon whether
I return true or false.
I'm going to, just to show what
we do, print the number
of wins and losses.
And then compute, how
does the house do?
Not the gambler, but the person
who's running the game,
the casino.
Or in other circumstances,
other places.
And then we'll see
how that goes.
And I'll try it with
100,000 games.
Now, this is more than 100,000
rolls of the dice, right?
Because I don't get a 7
or 11, I keep rolling.
So before I do it, I'll as the
easy question first. Who
thinks the casino wins more
often than the player?
Who thinks the player wins more
often than the casino?
Well, very logical, casinos are
not in business of giving
away money.
So now the more interesting
question.
How steep do you think the odds
are in the house's favor?
Anyone want to guess?
Actually pretty thin.
Let's run it and see.
So what we see is, the house
wins 50, in this case 50.424%
of the time.
Not a lot.
On the other hand, if
people bet 100,000,
the house wins 848.
Now, 100,000 is actually
a small number.
Let's get rid of these, should
have gotten rid of these
figures, you don't need to
see them every time.
We'll keep one figure,
just for fun.
Let's try it again.
Probably get a little
different answer.
Considerable different, but
still, less than 51% of the
time in this trial.
But you can see that the house
is slowly but surely going to
get rich playing this game.
Now let's ask the other
interesting question.
Just for fun, suppose
we want to cheat.
Now, I realize none of you
would never do that.
But let's consider using
a pair of loaded dice.
So there's a long history, well
you can imagine when you
looked at that old bone I showed
you, that it wasn't
exactly fair.
That some sides were a little
heavier than others, and in
fact you didn't get, say, a
5 exactly 1/6 of the time.
And therefore, if you were using
your own dice, instead
of somebody else's, and you knew
what was most likely, you
might do better.
Well, the modern version of that
is, people do cheat by
putting little weights in
dice, to just make tiny
changes in the probability
of one number or
another coming up.
So let's do that.
And let's first ask the
question, well, what would be
a nice way to do that?
It's very easy here.
If we look at it, all I've
done is, I've changed the
distribution of values, so
instead of here being 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, and 6, it's 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 5, and 6.
I snuck in an extra 5 on
one of the two dice.
So this has changed the odds of
rolling a 5 from 1 in 6 to
roughly 3 in 12.
Now 1/6, which is 2/12, vs.
3/12, it's not a big
difference.
And you can imagine, if you were
sitting there watching
it, you wouldn't notice that 5
was coming up a little bit
more often than you expected.
Normally.
Close enough that you
wouldn't notice it.
But let's see if, what
difference it makes?
What difference do you think
it will make here?
First of all, is it going
to be better or
worse for the player?
Who thinks better?
Who thinks worse?
Who thinks they haven't
a clue?
All right, we have
an honest man.
Where is Diogenes when
we we need him?
The reward for honesty.
I could reward you and wake
him up at the same time.
It's good.
All right, well, let's
see what happens.
All right, so suddenly, the odds
have swung in favor of
the player.
This tiny little change has now
made it likely that the
player win money, instead
of the house.
So what's the point?
The point is not, you should
go out and try and cheat
casinos, because you'll probably
find an unpleasant
consequence of that.
The point is that, once I've
written this simulation, I can
play thought experiments
in a very easy way.
So-called what if games.
What if we did this?
What if we did that?
And it's trivial to do those
kinds of things.
And that's one of the reasons we
typically do try and write
these simulations.
So that we can experiment
with things.
Are there any other experiments
people would like
to perform while we're here?
Any other sets of die you
might like to try?
All right, someone give me a
suggestion of something that
might work in the
house's favor.
Suppose a casino wanted
to cheat.
What do you think would
help them out?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Increase prevalence
of 1, instead of 5?
PROFESSOR: All right, so let's
see if we increase the
probability of 1,
what it does?
Yep, clearly helped the
house out, didn't it?
So that would be a good
thing for the house.
Again, you know, three key
strokes and we get to try it.
It's really a very nice kind
of thing to be able to do.
OK, this works nicely.
We'll get normal
distributions.
We can look at some things.
There are two other kinds
of distributions I
want to talk about.
We can get rid of this
distraction.
As you can imagine, I played a
lot with these things, just
cause it was fun
once I had it.
You have these in
your handout.
So the one on the upper right,
is the Gaussian, or normal,
distribution we've been
talking about.
As I said earlier, quite common,
we see it a lot.
The upper left is what's called
a, and these, by the
way, all of these distributions
are symmetric,
just in this particular
picture.
How do you spell symmetric,
one or two m's?
I help here.
That right?
OK, thank you.
And they're symmetric in the
sense that, if you take the
mean, it looks the same on
both sides of the mean.
Now in general, you can
have asymmetric
distributions as well.
But for simplicity, we'll here
look at symmetric ones.
So we've seen the bell curve,
and then on the upper left is
what's called the uniform.
In a uniform distribution, each
value in the range is
equally likely.
So to characterize it,
you only need to give
the range of values.
I say the values range from
0 to 100, and it tells me
everything I know about the
uniform distribution.
Each value in that will occur
the same number of times.
Have we seen a uniform
distribution?
What have we seen that's
uniform here?
Pardon?
STUDENT: Playing dice.
PROFESSOR: Playing dice.
Exactly right.
Each roll of the die
was equally likely.
Between 1 and 6.
So, we got a normal distribution
when I summed
them, but if I gave you the
distribution of a single die,
it would have been
uniform, right?
So there's an interesting
lesson there.
One die, the distribution was
uniform, but when I summed
them, I ended up getting
a normal distribution.
So where else do we see them?
In principle, lottery winners
are uniformly distributed.
Each number is equally
likely to come up.
To a first approximation,
birthdays are uniformly
distributed, things like that.
But, in fact, they rarely
arise in nature.
You'll hardly ever run a physics
experiment, or a
biology experiment, or anything
like that, and come
up with a uniform
distribution.
Nor do they arise very often in
complex systems. So if you
look at what happens in
financial markets, none of the
interesting distributions
are uniform.
You know, the prices of stocks,
for example, are
clearly not uniformly
distributed.
Up days and down days in the
stock market are not uniformly
distributed.
Winners of football games are
not uniformly distributed.
People seem to like to use
them in games of chance,
because they seem fair, but
mostly you see them only in
invented things, rather
than real things.
The third kind of distribution,
the one in the
bottom, is the exponential
distribution.
That's actually quite common
in the real world.
It's often used, for example,
to model arrival times.
If you want to model the
frequency at which, say,
automobiles arrive, get on the
Mass Turnpike, you would find
that the arrivals
are exponential.
We see with an exponential is,
things fall off much more
steeply around the mean than
with the normal distribution.
All right, that make sense?
What else is exponentially
distributed?
Requests for web pages are
often exponentially
distributed.
The amount of traffic
at a website.
How frequently they arrive.
We'll see much more starting
next week, or maybe even
starting Thursday, about
exponential distributions, as
we go on with a final case study
that we'll be dealing
with in the course.
You can think of each of
these, by the way, as
increasing order of
predictability.
Uniform distribution means the
result is most unpredictable,
it could be anything.
A normal distribution says,
well, it's pretty predictable.
Again, depending on the
standard deviation.
If you guess the mean, you're
pretty close to right.
The exponential is
very predictable.
Most of the answers are
right around the mean.
Now there are many other
distributions, there are
Pareto distributions which
have fat tails, there are
fractal distributions, there
are all sorts of things.
We won't go into to
those details.
Now, I hope you didn't find
this short excursion into
statistics either too boring
or too confusing.
The point was not to teach you
statistics, probability, we
have multiple courses
to do that.
But to give you some tools that
would help improve your
intuition in thinking
about data.
In closing, I want to give
a few words about
the misuse of data.
Since I think we misuse
data an awful lot.
So, point number 0, as in the
most important, is beware of
people who give you properties
of data, but not the data.
We see that sort of thing
all the time.
Where people come in, and they
say, OK, here it is, here's
the mean value of the quiz,
and here's the standard
deviation of the quiz, and that
just doesn't really tell
you where you stand,
in some sense.
Because it's probably not
normally distributed.
You want to see the data.
At the very least, if you see
the data, you can then say,
yeah, it is normally
distributed, so the standard
deviation is meaningful,
or not meaningful.
So, whenever you can,
try and get, at
least, to see the data.
So that's 1, or 0.
1 is, well, all right.
I'm going to test your Latin.
Cum hoc ergo propter hoc.
All right.
I need a Latin scholar
to translate this.
Did not one of you take
Latin in high school?
We have someone who did.
Go ahead.
STUDENT: I think it
means, with this,
therefore, because of this.
PROFESSOR: Exactly right.
With this, therefore,
because of this.
I'm glad that at least
one person
has a classical education.
I don't, by the way.
Essentially what this is
telling us, is that
correlation does not
imply causation.
So sometimes two things
go together.
They both go up, they
both go down.
And people jump to the
conclusion that
one causes the other.
That there's a cause and
effect relationship.
That is just not true.
It's what's called a
logical fallacy.
So we see some examples
of this.
And you can get into
big trouble.
So here's a very interesting
one.
There was a very widely reported
epidemiological
study, that's a medical study
where you get statistics about
large populations.
And it showed that women, who
are taking hormone replacement
therapy, were found to have a
lower incidence of coronary
heart disease than
women who didn't.
This was a big study
of a lot of women.
This led doctors to propose
that hormone replacement
therapy for middle aged women
was protective against
coronary heart disease.
And in fact, in response to
this, a large number of
medical societies recommended
this.
And a large number of women
were given this therapy.
Later, controlled trials showed
that in fact, hormone
replacement therapy in women
caused a small and significant
increase in coronary
heart disease.
So they had taken the fact that
these were correlated,
said one causes the other, made
a prescription, and it
turned out to be
the wrong one.
Now, how could this be?
How could this be?
It turned out that the women in
the original study who were
taking the hormone replacement
therapy, tended to be from a
higher socioeconomic group
than those who didn't.
Because the therapy was not
covered by insurance, so the
women who took it
were wealthy.
Turns out wealthy people do a
lot of other things that are
protective of their hearts.
And, therefore, are in general
healthier than poor people.
This is not a surprise.
Rich people are healthier
than poor people.
And so in fact, it was this
third variable that was
actually the meaningful one.
This is what is called in
statistics, a lurking variable.
Both of the things they were
looking at in this study, who
took the therapy, and who had a
heart disease, each of those
was correlated with the
lurking variable of
socioeconomic position.
And so, in effect, there
was no cause and effect
relationship.
And once they did another study,
in which the lurking
variable was controlled, and
they looked at heart disease
among rich women separately
from poor women, with this
therapy, they discovered that
therapy was not good.
It was, in fact, harmful.
So this is a very important
moral to remember.
When you look at correlations,
don't assume cause and effect.
And don't assume that there
isn't a lurking variable that
really is the dominant factor.
So that's one statistical, a
second statistical worry.
Number 2 is, beware of what's
called, non-response bias.
Which is another fancy
way of saying,
non-representative samples.
No one doing a study beyond
the trivial can sample
everybody or everything.
And only mind readers can be
sure of what they've missed.
Unless, of course,
people choose to
miss things on purpose.
Which you also see.
And that brings me to
my next anecdote.
A former professor at the
University of Nebraska, who
later headed a group called The
Family Research Institute,
which some of you may have heard
about, claimed that gay
men have an average life
expectancy of 43 years.
And they did a study full of
statistics showing that this
was the case.
And the key was, they calculated
the figure by
checking gay newspapers for
obituaries and news about
stories of death.
So they went through the gay
newspapers, took a list of
everybody whose obituary
appeared, how old they were
when they died, took the
average, and said it was 43.
Then they did a bunch of
statistics, with all sorts of
tests, showing how, you know,
what the curves look like, the
distributions, and
the significance.
All the math was valid.
The problem was, it was a very
unrepresentative sample.
What was the most
unrepresentative
thing about it?
Somebody?
STUDENT: Not all deaths
have obituaries.
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
one thing.
That's certainly true.
But what else?
Well, not all gay people
are dead, right?
So if you're looking at
obituaries, you're in fact
only getting --
I'm sure that's what you were
planning to say -- sorry.
You're only getting the people
who are dead, so it's clearly
going to make the number
look smaller, right?
Furthermore, you're only getting
the ones that were
reported in newspapers, the
newspapers are typically
urban, rather than out in rural
areas, so it turns out,
it's also biased against gays
who chose not come out of the
closet, and therefore didn't
appear in these.
Lots and lots of things
with the problems.
Believe it or not, this
paper was published
in a reputable journal.
And someone checked all the
math, but missed the fact that
all of that was irrelevant
because the sample was wrong.
Data enhancement.
It even sounds bad, right?
You run an experiment, you get
your data, and you enhance it.
It's kind of like when you ran
those physics experiments in
high school, and you've got
answers that you knew didn't
match the theory, so you
fudged the data?
I know none of you would have
ever done that, but some
people been known to do.
That's not actually
what this means.
What this means is, reading
more into the data than it
actually implies.
So well-meaning people are
often the guiltiest here.
So here's another one
of my favorites.
For example, there are people
who try to scare us into
driving safely.
Driving safely is
a good thing.
By telling holiday deaths.
So you'll read things like,
400 killed on the highways
over long weekend.
It sounds really bad, until
you observe the fact that
roughly 400 people are killed
on any 3-day period.
And in fact, it's no higher
on the holiday weekends.
I'll bet you all thought
more people got
killed on holiday weekends.
Well, typically not.
They just report how many died,
but they don't tell you
the context, say, oh, by the
way, take any 3-day period.
So the moral there is, you
really want to place the data
in context.
Data taken out of context
without comparison is usually
meaningless.
Another variance of this
is extrapolation.
A commonly quoted statistic.
Most auto accidents happen
within 10 miles of home.
Anyone here heard
that statistic?
It's true, but what
does it mean?
Well, people tend to say it
means, it's dangerous to drive
when you're near home.
But in fact, most driving is
done within 10 miles of home.
Furthermore, we don't actually
know where home is.
Home is where the car is
supposedly garaged on the
state registration forms. So,
data enhancements would
suggest that I should register
my car in Alaska.
And then I would never be
driving within 10 miles of
home, and I would
be much safer.
Well, it's probably
not a fact.
So there are all sorts
of things on that.
Well, I think I will come back
to this, because I have a
couple more good stories which
I hate not to give you.
So we'll come back on Thursday
and look at a couple of more
things that can go wrong
with statistics.